today I'm gonna be melting 10,000
starbursts into a giant pot and then
pouring it into a mold of my head
apparently like spirits like that's like
not good like you can lose a part of
your soul by putting it into food and
having people eating it which is kind of
scary but then also it's kind of cool
because then I get to live forever
inside of people I literally am not
entirely sure this is gonna work but
what's the worst that could happen also
don't try this at home let's get to the
star base we're going to put the
starburst into the melting bowl and
we're gonna turn on the hot plate and a
hot plate steam is gonna melt the
starbursts let's get to it
this is what I'm gonna be known for I
want to live forever in starburst or
Pharaohs yeah Dan was saying that
Pharaohs who have death masks like I
wasn't they do it with starbursts
obviously but they will make a mask of
their face to live forever I've had my
face demoralized and not a mask like a
but there was something about it where I
really enjoyed it yeah I know I
meditated during it I literally was just
like I just zoned out
Wow this is gonna take a lot of time
three out of its day Phil we are going
to boil water on our hot pot while
that's happening I thought we shouldn't
wrap more
[Music]
much much much later I hear the sizzle I
know it's silly
[Music]
Alexandria helps me microwave and it is
working way better than this pot so
seems like microwaving is the way to go
I feel like I've been melting starbursts
for the past three hours because I have
I feel like I need a pore quicker next
time this took a lot of time but a lot
of care went into it and so half of my
head is done so we're going to go put it
in the freezer and then let it freeze
and they use these knives to shove it
out the next day like sort of getting
there with the starbursts me it is
taking and absorbing that time I did not
know that we're gonna turn this will
pull on our project but because of that
I think I might make an art gallery put
this as a centerpiece so that will be
fun okay look at that yeah what do we
have here
wow this feels [ __ ] about 35 pounds of
starbursts head we're gonna fuse the two
halves together
using a heat gun I was talking to Dan
and he was like we should put it on
display and so that's what we did
Taney ously like really impressed and
really grossed out dr. scam but you got
a good looking at bone structure though
I mean are you new but like this really
highlights it got good looking hey it's
like your brains
I guess the beauty is that it's done and
it was made and people got to experience
they say we're not ready to think you
died I see I was gonna toss it no to the
bottom of it this is how like a mother
feels
I put the head sculpture into the
freezer and then I'm gonna put resin on
it so I can save it as an art sculpture
forever that way no food is wasted
[Music]